i don't wear a cape there's never been a
marvel movie like eternals with a story
that spans over centuries a focus on
natural light and locations and the very
first openly lgbtq plus mcu hero
eternals is a game changer i definitely
feel like a bad guy in a rocky movie
kumail nanjiani turned a lot of heads
when he revealed just how in shape he
got to play kingo in eternals the
pakistani american comedian revealed
that neither the film's director chloe
zhao nor marvel themselves had asked
nanjiani to get in shape for the role in
fact the filmmaker was a bit upset
initially about nanjiani's decision and
wanted the team of eternals to have body
types of all kinds and of various ages
nanjiani's response was a classy one if
i'm playing the first south asian
superhero i want to look like someone
who can take on thor or captain america
or any of those people
eternals marks a major milestone in the
mcu as it features the first openly gay
hero in the franchise in brian tyree
henry's fastos the film also holds the
distinction as the first superhero movie
to feature a prominent same-sex kiss
which was between fastos and his human
husband haas slayman who plays fastos's
husband described the kiss as an
emotional and beautiful moment on set
everyone cried on set for me it's very
important to show how loving and
beautiful a queer family can be
well i'm sure that was fun for you it
was marvel is no stranger to recruiting
the biggest a-list stars in the business
to star in their films but angelina
jolie who will be playing thena is
easily one of the biggest names to ever
join the mcu jolie is no stranger to
action films though unlike her previous
experiences training for blockbusters
jolie's training routine for eternals
was a bit different than what she was
used to because of the extensive cgi
used in eternals jolie had to train
using weapons that she wouldn't even be
wielding on set of the film julie also
took ballet lessons to prepare for the
choreography of her role
marvel is notoriously secretive about
all of their films which means that
sometimes even the stars themselves are
kept in the dark after a couple of slips
sorry mark ruffalo and tom holland
lauren ridloff who plays marvel's first
deaf superhero makari revealed just how
committed marvel is to keeping things
covert according to ridloff marvel
legitimately sent a man in a trench coat
to show up to her house at 11 at night
with pages of the script disclosed in a
manila envelope to add an even greater
sense of secrecy marvel would take the
previous night script pages in exchange
for the new ones while ridloff found the
experience genuinely funny salma hayek
who plays ajak grew frustrated it
freaked me out and i hated it and i was
angry about it they didn't want me to
keep the script i'd make my notes and
they'd take it away they give you
another one but they take the old one i
like to keep my stuff
i didn't know you could go out and shoot
real places chloe zhao is a filmmaker
who always goes the extra mile to make
her films look good the brass at marvel
studios allowed her to keep many of her
directorial sensibilities to the film
much like her previous films zhao shot
eternals in natural locations all while
using natural light according to nate
moore a producer of eternals shot more
outdoor exterior shots than any other
film in the mcu unlike the typical look
of the other mcu films zhao opted to go
for a color scheme that would look more
blue and focus on daylight
so what do you want to see how about
sack lunch it's not unusual for marvel
films to use fake names during their
production in fact it's common practice
for the studio for example chongqi's
fake name during production was
steamboat the production names given to
the films are typically inside jokes
between the creative minds at marvel and
the production name given to eternals
was sack lunch funnily enough the name
stems from a joke on the classic 90s
sitcom seinfeld as sack lunch was the
name of a fake movie on the show don't
keegan has always been a fan of marvel
and has wanted to play a superhero for
quite some time as can be proven from
his social media out of all the main
cast members keegan was actually the
last one to get into costume for his
character when i arrived and put it on
for the first time it was kind of nice
to walk out and see the rest of the
cast's reaction they were like whoa it's
a weird feeling to see yourself like
that as soon as you put the boots on
your posture transforms you definitely
notice how your whole demeanor and
everything just changes
ridloff's makari is known for her super
speed so naturally ridloff started to
partake in running to help train for her
role though the production team didn't
agree with ridloff's methods and told
her to stop really what they wanted to
do was focus on building the symmetry of
somebody who looks like a sprinter and
they tend to be a bit more muscular so i
focused mostly on building muscle
especially my legs hey who's your
gardener the eternals team needed a
location that would look authentic when
showing the eternals first arriving on
earth in 5000 bc one notable moment had
the crew filming scenes on top of what
chloe zhao described as the windiest
cliff she had ever been on we had our
whole cast standing on that cliff in
their costumes and we played really loud
operatic music on the speaker just
blasting that through the wind zhao
claimed that the wind was so brutal that
she could barely stand while filming the
scene it's just like
wow leah mchugh may be the youngest out
of the eternals cast but her character
sprite is actually the same age as her
team members
before eternals mchugh was used to
working in smaller horror projects such
as the blumhouse and hulu anthology
series into the dark and the lodge doing
stunts on the set of eternals was a
whole new experience mchugh took every
opportunity she could to perform her own
stunts towards the beginning of filming
i was in a harness doing this crazy
choreographed stunt scene and i just
remember thinking wow my brothers are
going to think i'm so cool kingo
vista i've directed some things too
kumil nanjiani's kingo is not one who
avoids the limelight as in the film he's
one of the biggest bollywood stars on
the planet as we all know you can't be a
bollywood star without being a good
dancer first which became a bit of a
problem for nanjiani i have zero rhythm
i had to take months and months of
classes to do this nanjiani grew up
watching bollywood films so he wanted
his dance scene to feel special as well
as capturing the joy and excitement of
the dance numbers in bollywood films
this is new chapter new life new
beginning
south korean star don lee plays
gilgamesh in the eternals who has the
power to take out his enemies with a
single punch the role would require lee
to partake in boxing training as his
fight choreography was inspired by the
sport luckily lee is a lifelong boxer
and has been partaking in it for over 30
years lee even added real boxing
movements on set while filming the fight
scenes how can we have this big melting
pot
and cook up something
that might just taste a little bit
different
most of zhao's filmography thus far has
been bordering on more serious and
prestige fare so with eternals she knew
she had to balance the drama with all
the sci-fi weirdness and even bring in
that classic mcu humor what was this
even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea even for a director as highly
esteemed as zhao she embraced
collaboration especially when it came to
figuring out all the complicated vfx
work and the film's countless action set
pieces
jack kirby and his imagination his
incredible work is really the foundation
of it for visual inspiration for
eternals chloe zhao turned to the
creator of the eternals comic book
legend jack kirby none of this is
possible without jack kirby's brilliant
creation that was a huge part of it for
us from the design of the spaceship to
the tiniest symbol on the costumes to
what their powers look like amazing cast
and such a diverse cast chloe zhao is
known for working with non-professional
actors in her films despite the high
status of the cast she said that she
didn't focus on star power but instead
finding actors who she felt could
especially identify with their roles on
set she encouraged every cast member to
find something about themselves in each
of their characters she wasn't looking
to put something on top of us like a
character she was looking for us to
reveal ourselves as the character
it's abundantly clear just how
passionate the production team were when
making eternals from getting the
characters right bringing a personal
touch and making the film more relatable
and accessible for audiences from all
walks of life who is your favorite
eternal